all right we are live again for another
philosophy pop up session this is the
second one in November we do one on
YouTube live and one on Facebook live
for different people in different places
we don't have anyone on yet so I'm
actually going to give it a minute or so
before I get started and post a few
things here and there so we've already
got two people now chiming in we'll give
it a few more minutes and I'll talk a
bit bye bye we have preface about the
the topic that I'm going to start with
so this month we had our free webinar
and our intensive online seminars
focused on Friedrich Nietzsche and I
also did a talk here locally in the
Milwaukee area the sort of placing
Nietzsche in in his historical
perspective I'm talking about the
problem of nihilism which which
Nietzsche saw is really the problem that
we would be facing in the 20th and 21st
century and how his philosophy was
supposed to explain how we got there and
then be sort of uh in his view a kind of
a remedy for that and I think that that
fits in very well with the theme of his
first work the birth of tragedy although
he doesn't use the word nihilism their
word that he'll use quite frequently in
his later works I should mention as well
that I also did a session with the pants
ICAST podcast along with mark from the
partially examined life specifically on
Nietzsche where you know we talked quite
a bit about different aspects of nature
but a controversy in the discussion as
well and that should be airing I think
they said at the end of December so it's
going to be a little while before that
one comes out
let me quickly post the live link in a
few places and so yeah the meet in the
meantime while I'm doing that I'll just
tell you you know I've been teaching
Nietzsche for a long time and I think
the birth of tragedy is very interesting
work nature kind of downplayed it a bit
I think that if there's a lot of really
cool stuff going on there but I also
find a lot of people getting mixed up
and mistaken about it
there we go so I wanted to you know
focus on a mat and talk about these
three noble responses the first noble
response is the DNA siak response the
second is the Apollonian and the third
is what nietzsche calls the socratic so
any attempt to try to view just a simple
dualism there is kind of a mistake but I
do wind up seeing quite a few mostly
artistic folks trying to interpret the
birth of tragedy along those lines
all right just got to post it in two
more places and then we will get started
in earnest there we go and you know me
I'm all about reaching out in social
media all right now if anybody hasn't
joined in by this time that is on them
so let's talk about about these three
noble responses and so I mentioned that
you know in the birth of tragedy
Nietzsche is you know very early on
talking about that what he calls the
problem of life and what he means by
that is you know
the realization that that from the
perspective that he's enunciated and
what he thinks a lot of you know smart
people have seen over the years going
all the way back into prehistory is that
life if it does have a meaning it's not
a simple one and it's one that we often
seem to somehow miss we tie ourselves in
with with things or projects or
movements ways of life that that seemed
to be satisfying seem to make sense and
then find out that that that's not
really the case and a Nietzsche actually
uses the word nausea to talk about the
affective experience of this and he
thinks that the you know these responses
to the problem of life are you know
things that we can diagnose across
cultures so there you might say ways of
responding to this this issue to this
global problem that we're gonna find
recurring in culture after culture
what's really interesting about the
birth of tragedy is that you know the
two responses that he begins talking
about at the start the DM misiek
response which is oriented towards like
the dynamism of life it's D
differentiating you might say it ends up
you know tying us into this primal unity
which is not at the same time a really
happy one but it's certainly an ecstatic
one there's that and then the Apollonian
represents order it sets dumb limits it
says you know you won't go any further
than this and he talks about it as like
a you know standing in the waves of the
DNS Ian and and limiting it um he
doesn't use the metaphor of a seawall
but I think that would be really
appropriate there and you know other
places the D&E siak exists but it
doesn't really reach its full potential
the way it did in Greece because when
it's just this dynamism this this you
know primal wearing things away
overcoming
obstacles like I said you know taking
individuals and D differentiating them
placing them back into this primal hole
it winds up you might say lapsing into a
kind of not full meaningfulness right it
uh it may accomplish that and you know
he looks at you know certain cultures
and he may be off base and this he
thinks that indian culture you know in
stressing the primal unity of things
that we think about indian philosophy
was capturing something of the dns yak
but it got kind of you know frozen in a
way it became less active the barbarians
he mentions you know the Phrygians and
also he talks about the Germans and the
Middle Ages and the Babylonians they
would have these DNA siak rights and
they would be you know getting really
into them and engaging in all sorts of
cruelty Nietzsche says that that sort of
thing doesn't really accomplish much
might feel really great at the time and
it might get you know your energies out
and and you know maybe adjust you back
to society in a certain way but it
doesn't really you know produce a
lasting effect the Apollonian is is what
allows the DN a-- siak in greece to
really become it's you know what is at
least i don't want to say it's full
potential but at least a good portion of
what its potential is and he thinks that
this happens the most in greek tragedy
in early Greek tragedy with Aeschylus
and Sophocles and the Apollonian you
might think of it as as static as you
know ordered or imposing itself but it's
really dynamic in its own way and
Nietzsche contrasts you know the Greek
Apollonian which is in in this dynamic
tension with the DNS yak against what he
calls an Egyptian rigidity right that he
associates with with Egyptian artwork or
with the Roman you know
ocular is a ssin the focus on the
political to the the you might say the
detriment of everything else those are
those are other ways of being Apollonian
that Nietzsche says are not as
productive as what the Greeks did and so
the Greeks you know if we think about
what tragedy really meant for them or at
least you know for the Athenians because
it's largely taking place there in
Athens this this composite is able to
bring both of these together and he
thinks that you have like a DM misiek
emphasis on the chorus on talking about
this primal unity of being and then you
have the Apollonia novel of the
individuals or the beautiful images and
there's somehow able to come together in
this dynamic tension and give us you
might say the best of both worlds at the
same time so that something was taking
place in an early Greek tragedy that
would later in effect get lost and the
reason why it gets lost is because of
what nietzsche calls the third noble
response to life which is what he at
that time calls the Socratic the other
terms that he uses for this are the the
the Alexandrian you know referring to
Hellenistic culture after the time of
the unifying of Greece under Philip and
and you know the creation of the you
might call it cosmopolitan economy the
Eco new McKay
under under Alexander we're Greek
culture spreading throughout the Middle
East but it's it's becoming a kind of
standardized culture in certain respects
no longer tied with a particularly
particular city-state it's also
identified with Alexandria itself where
all of this literary and scientific
activity was going on and then nature
will talk about scientific culture you
know from really what's going on from
the the Renaissance on in in modern
Europe and then eventually the world and
the Socratic response
is you know it's not the same thing as
the Apollonian I think a lot of readers
get mistaken ideas about what's going on
if they view the Socratic is merely like
the Apollonian taken to a higher power
or something like that because what
Nietzsche stresses about the Socratic
response and this is why it ends up
destroying Greek tragedy in the
narrative that he's telling us is that
it winds up being unduly optimistic and
rationalistic it thinks that the world
is in fact reasonable in a way that that
maybe the world is maybe the world isn't
but to say that it is if it represents a
kind of leap of faith and Socrates not
only thinks that the world is rational
but that the human being is
fundamentally rational you know the
reason why we do stupid things bad
things is ignorance you know virtue
amounts to wisdom and if we can just you
know sort of get ourselves on track
properly we're going to you know change
the world
Nietzsche talks about this response is
not just being a response that figures
out how the human being can can make it
in relation to this screwed-up world
that we live in but a response that
thing's thinks that we can correct the
world that we can make it better that in
this case we'll make an exception and
it'll be different for us and you know
Socrates has a a wingman you might say
in this story and that wingman is
Euripides the other playwright who
according to Nietzsche tries to take the
DNA siak element out of Greek tragedy
and in the result also loses the
Apollonian and substitutes something
else in its place something Socratic and
then just some artistic effects that
that you know you know in says in in
place of the Apollonian you have you
know dialogue that is essentially
philosophizing on the stage people
account you know giving accounts of what
they're doing nietzsche views this as as
leading to the death of old trad
and the rise of you know Euripides and
Agathon and tragedy after that he also
thinks something similar happened in
terms of old comedy and its transition
to new comedy which in his view is
equally superficial it can't satisfy the
fundamental deep demands that Greek
tragedy was in his views satisfying for
the Greeks and you know looking ahead he
views our own age as one that's
thoroughly dominated by the Socratic
spirit but it's reached at kind of
Twilight it's the Socratic spirit has
run itself out it's on the face
optimistic but it's optimism has been
kind of worn down it realizes its own
limitations and now the question is well
what will what will this open the path
to remember that these are not the only
possible responses to the problem of
life according to Nietzsche these are
the three noble responses there are
plenty of other responses as well you
know the the person who like lapses into
consumerism I don't think that Nietzsche
looking at that would say that that is
Apollonia nor Deanna siak or Socratic
it's something different
so Nietzsche is not saying these three
cover every person or every possible
culture or configuration but what he's
looking towards and what he hopes is
going to happen through German music
because at the time that he's writing
that he's kind of hitched his wagon to
two vogner star is that German music and
German philosophy will allow a sort of
reuniting of the the Apollonia and D&S
yet not in the exactly the same way as
happened in Greek tragedy but a new
configuration and so you know to sort of
bring this to a close if we were to
adopt nature's perspective which he says
was overly optimistic about something
like a national renewal if we were to
try to think about how this might apply
in our own present in a time when people
talk about this as being you know us
being in a postmodern condition
and there's many different viewpoints on
exactly what that means but a lot of
them you know are taking stock of what
Nietzsche is articulating in in the
birth of tragedy and it ends later works
if we were to you know think about that
and think about how the Socratic has
been kind of worn out and whether we
want to continue to identify with it or
whether we want to try to bring back in
something more DNS yak and something
more Apollonian the open question for
all of us I think is how would we how
would we do that
how what forms would that take place and
I don't actually have an answer to that
I haven't I haven't really thought that
out but I think that is something that
people have been struggling with and so
you see in the early 20th century a lot
of people reading the birth of tragedy
and saying yes we have to have a rebirth
of art we have to have a rebirth of
music we have to have a rebirth of this
and that so I don't actually have my own
answer to that worked out but I think
that this is a very interesting problem
that that he's posing and and I would
say you know that those who are doing
you know philosophy as a way of life you
know interesting person along those
lines
Jules Evans who I think many of you may
know he wants to you know sort of
recapture more the Dionysian element to
things and he he talks about the need to
bring that back in not to be hyper
rationalistic you might say about that
and so this is this is this you know is
something's definitely worth exploring
now I've talked for about 15 minutes I'm
gonna open things up to questions and
take some of those rather than simply
just chatter on take a sip of coffee too
so Heraclitus aphasia
rights I agree with a lot of his ideas
in the birth of tragedy without music
life would be a mistake I think with art
[Music]
yeah and you know
it's not as if music is only Dionysian
according to Nietzsche the Apollonian
has its own own brand of music he talks
about it as being kind of like you know
and when we watch those old 1950s
through 1970s movies about like Greeks
and Romans and you see somebody with a
lyre playing and it's very sedate and
you hear the little music in the
background that's what Nietzsche thinks
Apollonian music is is like Dena siak
music would be you know the stuff that's
like you know constantly moving and
pulsating and and bringing us in he
talks about you know the folk music and
I don't mean just like sitting around
and you know you know where your your
overalls and and and play on some some
conventional instruments can't afford
music I mean like the music that really
gets people into things I mean you could
say that that's part of what makes a D&S
act that the person who's listening gets
captivated by the music so in many
respects I would say that contemporary
metal and a lot of rock and roll manages
to bring together the DNA siak and the
Apollonia and very interesting ways
there was a musical form that Nietzsche
actually said was quite Socratic opera
he thought that opera was about as low
as you could possibly go in music and he
wasn't talking about vogner at that time
he was talking about you know the kind
of light fare people would go and you
know they're I mean you don't really
have to if you're going to the Opera at
that time you're really going to be seen
and maybe they listen to some nice music
you don't know you're not really paying
that close attention to it or if you are
it's a nice simple story that you can
easily get into it's sort of like
watching a sitcom with lots of musical
accompaniment
I suppose that Nietzsche would probably
look at contemporary and you know the
1900s musical theatre and say something
quite similar you know like if yous
watching Camelot or something along
those lines
I don't know I don't know if you've
considered all of that to fit under that
sort of rubric but you know yeah you're
right music is is very important to to
this now design belen writes how do you
think wonder fits in or does it so you
know that's a great question you know
the post Socratic you know platonic and
Rishta Tilian philosophies stress that
philosophy begins and wonder and I think
there's there's something to that I
don't think it always begins there I
agree with Epictetus that sometimes
philosophy begins with you know seeing
people saying different things about the
same ideas or issues and wondering well
how the hell can all these people not be
on the same page right and trying to
figure out where would I actually get
the answers that I'm looking for but
wonder so you know the Apollonian
involves wonder it involves that sort of
being in rapt attention to the images
imagine listening to a Homeric epic
being recited to you and having these
ideas about the battles of the gods and
human beings or the struggles of
Odysseus there's a kind of wonder
involved in that I think there could be
another kind of wonder or maybe we might
use a different word I don't know like
awe or even nature talks about terror
involved in the D&S siak but I think
that there's also something involved in
the Socratic and I think this is why
Nietzsche at least in his early work is
quite willing to say that the Socratic
is a noble response whereas in his later
works he is going to call it a ignoble
base response so I think that's quite an
interesting idea there is a kind of
wonder that that goes on with the
Socratic you know and it's
it might be a wonder at something that's
not quite there the rationality of the
whole you know maybe it's projecting
something outward there in the world
that isn't isn't truly there in the
world this is part of what Nietzsche
took can't himself this way nature
thought they can't instead of being a
rationalist was actually one of the
people sort of undermining the whole
Socratic Enterprise in in this this work
and leading to Schopenhauer so yeah
wonder could could mean a lot of
different things and then of course
there could be just the you know sort of
gaping Oh wonder of you know watching
puppets or something like that that
nature I don't think would associate
with with any of these responses you
know just kind of trivial stuff right
all right here cleitus writes opera is
low today we'd say it's hired so to
speak yeah and I think that kind of
points to something quite interesting
about our our culture Nietzsche is is
engaged in what he later characterized
as a genealogical Enterprise at a
genealogical mode of inquiry tries to
sort of peel back the layers of stuff
that we have you know ended up sort of
not overlaying the the realities that
we're digging into which originally had
much less noble or you know sort of
global origins we could say they
originated in how people were actually
living out their lives you know great
example of this I have a video
specifically on this with the the
genealogy is punishment
it just says punishment there's a lot of
interesting theories about why we punish
and none of these are actually correct
because punishment itself is a complex
thing that that developed over time and
responded to certain needs in human
society so you know opera becomes for us
what the rich people
the cool people and the powerful people
get to indulge in so we can have it like
you know Batman Batman's parents get
killed you know coming back from the
Opera and it makes perfect sense oh you
know these are rich people you know they
they get to enjoy high art I think
there's there's quite a quite a bit of
that stuff and I think if Nietzsche were
around today he would look at a lot of
what people call postmodern in art and
say that's just a generate crap you know
this this endless irony and playing
around with like you know putting your
little brand on something and and you
know he'd probably look at the whole
kind of hipster culture and and just
throw his hands up in despair you know I
was reading something today
somebody was was writing and they
referenced ironic facial hair right and
I don't even know what the hell that
means you know you you what you grow a
beard or a funny mustache because you're
making a statement but you're not really
making a statement I mean they have the
speaking of it's they have the luxury to
be able to do that is is just you know
bizarre and that one's life could you
know that could be like the apex of
one's existence strikes me as really
weird and I think Nietzsche would look
at that sort of thing and say wow this
is this is not a noble response at all
in some respect but within our society I
think for many people I mean we could
change the word Noble into something
like you know meaningful in a genuine
sense or a substitute the word cool
right I think for a lot of people what
Nietzsche is talking about is Noble it
would be something understood as cool
maybe we have a mistaken view point on
what constitute really viable ways of
existence that can lend a person
person's life real meaning in response
to the problem of life
or maybe Nietzsche was too restrictive
in how he thought about it I suppose
that would be you know up to others to
say all right I don't see any other
questions or comments in the live chat
window so I'll just talk a little bit
about what we've got coming up this this
this month ahead of us and then we'll
see if anybody else wants to ask
anything or say anything to me about
Nietzsche can be about anything else you
like I'll read your response and and
then say my piece in relation to it so
we're kind of winding down I I did 12
talks in five different locations over
the last month and a half and this week
you know this Thanksgiving week is the
first week where I other than online
things like this I don't have any other
things that I have to do I don't have to
show up anywhere to talk about things so
I really you know I'm playing a bit of
catch-up I don't I've only got a few
in-person things here in the Milwaukee
area one is is in that that speculative
fiction and philosophy series the others
and the women authors that you should
read and I'll be talking about some
interesting stuff there but this month
for the online events that we're doing
I'm going back to focus on epictetus and
I will be talking about choice and how
he understands choice and character how
it is that we form our characters so you
could say we're going back into the
socratic and that's you know how how it
can it would fit in from Nietzsche's
perspective Nietzsche was pretty tough
on the Stoics you didn't always have a
lot of great stuff to say about them ah
looks like we've got a question right
here what do I think about Nietzsche's
political views is the aphagia stand
anarchists
something else that's a good question
he's definitely not a fascist you know
historically fascism comes on the scene
in the 20th century
Nietzsche dies at the beginning of the
20th century you might say well maybe
he's a proto-fascist or something like
that I think if you look at the
historical movements and even a lot of
the theorists even though they they
often drew upon Nietzsche as well as you
know other sources as well it's not a
great fit to say that he would be a
fascist
you know fascism is it's kind of a
complicated matter anyway I you know
when I say fascism - by the way I don't
mean the sort of simplistic views on it
that you know like the Marxist have that
it's just you know this this sort of
spin off of capitalism or you know the
even like lower thing where anybody you
don't like who's an authoritarian is a
fascist we want to make a very strong
differentiation if we want to the word
to mean anything between you know
military dictatorships that are actually
conservative but but not fascist in
order to be a fascist you have to focus
on mobilizing the masses you have to you
know essentially pivot yourself between
left and right in in many ways you know
you can't certainly you certainly may
co-opt the the traditional right and
definitely there's there's what's called
Helena Genesis right which means a focus
on the you know sort of old origins of
things but it takes it you know takes
all these different characteristics to
be fascist and then you know along the
same spectrum there's National Socialism
and all that and Bob is right that
fascist some fascists do have a weird
fascination with him some I think
actually you know reject him and I think
a lot of the people who have
been really fascinated it focused just
on they focus very selectively on parts
of Nietzsche's philosophy so they might
have liked the you know the
anti-establishment anti Christianity
part but then they kind of ignored like
a great example when it comes to like
anti-semitism Nietzsche he was in a
sense an anti-semite
but he was the kind of anti-semite who
thought that anti-semitism was about as
low as you could possibly go in
intellectual life right he you know he
criticizes Judaism as well as even more
so Christianity for how things played
out in history but the the kind of low
low class you know let's let's round up
the Jews sort of thing Nietzsche would
have said you guys are just trash you
know so it now is Nietzsche an anarchist
Heraclitus is asking wouldn't nature be
a super individualist yes no I mean it's
hard to say exactly who Nietzsche looks
up to and you know there are some
examples in the people that he lauds
of political figures he certainly he is
an individualist in this sense right
that he thinks that the way society has
developed if you're taking your cues
primarily from society you're going to
be robbing yourself of the opportunity
to fully develop and you're gonna be
going into some cul-de-sacs or dead ends
and so you know anything where we might
like take a vote about it to decide
whether it's good or bad II you know
it's gonna be a problem for it for
Nietzsche it's interesting you know when
I gave that talk recently I mentioned
that Nietzsche would have you know not
been for American Idol right where we
simply vote on who the the good
candidates are and then we have these
kind of you know
placeholder judges who do their little
shtick you know and and and all that and
it's generally you know been sort of
pre-selected to give us musical talent
but it's in a very digested form and
somebody got really worked up over his I
don't like you having examples about
that sort of thing and you should you
know shouldn't be bringing that up in
terms of Nietzsche and I mean if nature
were around in the present he would be
criticizing those sorts of things you
know you look at what he was criticizing
in his works at the time a lot of it was
matters of the popular culture of his
day so I think that's perfectly
legitimate if we want to try to extend
his thought into the present so I'm
gonna springboard over a dozen melons
comment and come back to that because
our tips sick news writes Nietzsche
admired vogner for what he represents it
essentially as a signifier but do you
think Nietzsche thought musicians and
artists themselves as an occupation
qualified as nobility no definitely not
I mean historically musicians and
artists you know for the most part have
been people who work for somebody who
might actually be you know in a one-up
position there there have been cases
where and it goes all the way back to
ancient Greece where there was some
autonomy of the artists you know in
relation to the both the product and the
patron but that was not the case for
most artists and Stu I would say is not
the case today I mean if you're a
musician you make your money playing
weddings if you're a photographer you
make your your money photographing
weddings we're doing headshots or stuff
like that and then you get to do your
other stuff on the side and very very
very few people really enjoy a lot of
autonomy except if they do it on the on
the side or if they want to be you know
starving artists and I don't think that
Nietzsche would consider a person who
does that to be automatically noble
right
I mean they certainly could be that way
but it would require having talent and
that's not something you can take for
granted among everybody yeah and and I
understand in terms of the explication
of noble virtues or rather not noble
virtues but rather than noble valuation
of life I mean there could be artists
who have that that Nietzschean
perspective on things many of them
probably won't be artists working in
artistic media many of them will be
artists working in the media of business
organizations or you know language in
general or other things there's you know
there's no there's no reason why it
would be confined to the arts but all
that said there's nothing to prevent
artists from from adopting that sort of
point of view I don't know that that
nature provides more than just kind of
intellectual springboard he certainly
doesn't lay out for the practicing
artist or musician a program of exactly
what they want to be doing so you know
now I'm going to skip back very quickly
to 2000 balance point because then bobs
thing ties in nicely with that to new
translations of the phenomenology of
spirit on Amazon now for pre-order both
very expensive well that's good that
they're out there I imagine one of them
is ping Kurds translation which has been
floating around for a while that I have
a I have a PDF of a draft of which is
quite good in some respects it's more
faithful translation than than the
Miller translation which is kind of the
standard English translation now at the
time I suppose you know ten years from
now perhaps ping Kurds translation will
supplant it but it's not going to do so
right away because there's so much
already invested in using that
you know now older translation just as
there was in using Bailey's earlier
translation as well there's so much
literature out there that is citing the
Miller translation it's gonna take a
while to adjust and and I don't know
that you know but it comes down to it I
don't think that you have to have you
know the newest translation suppose it's
important for for scholarship but often
times you know there's no such thing as
like the best translation in in most
cases and you know we can say it's some
similar thing about Nietzsche as well
that people are always well which which
which one do I have to get you know
which which translation and I always say
well I don't know you know I mean if I
if I get concerned about how the
translation seems to play itself out I
just go to the original anyway Nietzsche
is somebody who's actually fun to read
in in German Hegel Hinkle's not really
that fun to read in German or English
and you not all that fun to read in
French either in HIPPA leads to
translation but but it's worth reading
so let's take Nietzsche's let's take Bob
Knight's thing what do you have to say
about the relation between Nietzsche and
Hegel so you know Nietzsche did not see
himself as a Hegelian it was kind of
hard at the time I think to avoid
contact with the hag aliens and he in
his self-criticism he actually says that
his early work the birth of tragedy is a
little bit to a galleon but I wouldn't
say that there's a hell of a lot of
relation between them other than the
fact that they're occupying some of the
same cultural space you know people
sometimes try to do compare and contrast
you know like Hegel's master-slave
dialectic versus Nietzsche's discussion
of master morality and slave morality
and they don't really map onto
each other that well in part because
Hegel's master-slave dialectic is really
just one little portion of the entire
work which doesn't doesn't really
deserve to be blown up into like not key
to hague all the way that i think a lot
of 20th and some 21st century thinkers
have done in part because they you know
find it convenient right dad said you
know i'm not knocking the master-slave
dialectic it's an interesting thing but
i don't think you get that much mileage
out of comparing the two of them against
each other if these are supposed to be
understood as like world historical
stuff so bob follows up saying would it
be possible to implement parts of
nature's philosophy in the Hegel's
system of science i know of course
nietzsche was very anti system i mean i
don't know i'm not sure why one would
want to do that i mean and what are we
talking about in terms of Hegel's system
of science if we're if we're talking
about like the historical development of
consciousness laid out in the
phenomenology i think that kind of
stands on its own and you know I am
already somebody who says I'm not
following Hegel all the way to absolute
knowing and I think there's some big
gaps in here but there's some cool stuff
along the way I'm not one of these
people who says well either you buy the
whole hog alien system or you don't buy
any of it which included Hegel by the
way he kind of thought that way I think
that that's a mistake you know can you
take some of the dynamics that meetcha
is talking about some of the dynamics
that Hegel is talking about and bring
them together sure I mean that's that's
been sort of a a stock-in-trade of
French and German intellectuals in the
the 20th century you know whether we're
talking about the Frankfurt School or
we're talking about you know French
Nietzsche inspired you know
post-structuralist thought
there are a lot of them are doing things
like that I guess the question is what
you want to take from from Bill thinkers
and what mileage you want to get from
that and there's nothing that says that
just because Nietzsche was the
anti-systemic that you can't you can't
you know systematize what he's doing or
trying to import it into a a larger
system it's not like he has you know
some sort of absolute prohibition on you
ever do yeah right it's just a question
of the the eclecticism that you're
adopting how well are you able to
integrate these components with each
other and that that's sort of a general
question not just for Nietzsche and
Hegel but I think for philosophy in
general you know people will say for
example for me right I I draw very
heavily on the Aristotelian tradition I
draw very heavily on the Platonic
tradition both through platanus like
like Plutarch and also through you know
various Jewish and Christian platanus I
draw very heavily on the Stoics I also
draw very heavily on existential thought
how can you possibly you know hold all
of these together they contradict each
other on certain points yeah sure they
do so I'm not I'm not saying that I I
take you know like say Aristotle system
and then just shove everybody else into
that and find a category it's more of a
dynamic process right and and I've
actually one of the things I said
because it's kind of cool realization
recently in the stoic forums was I don't
call myself a stoic but I probably
understand and practice more stoic
philosophy than many of the beginners
who are really enthused about it and
self-identifying as as Stoics you know
and similarly you know a my interest
Italian MA and existentialist yeah I
kind of you know I'm willing to say okay
about that and then I'll
but I don't agree with him on this and I
don't agree with them on that and I
think that that's really you know you
see that a lot in in the history of
philosophy Aristotle himself was doing
that you know this great Stoics we're
doing that bringing together things
along those lines Aquinas --is model is
something like that you know this
assimilates have an integrative work
it's an ongoing theme all right I may
have missed another thing that neo
Pelagian was asking ya earlier would
Nietzsche voted for Trump he asks and
isn't Nietzsche just a practical and a
galleon well I mean Hegel was a
practical a galleon you know I think
hails work when we read it closely it's
saying listen unless ideas actually do
become practical they're not really much
as ideas but I'm not sure what it would
mean for Nietzsche to be a practical
Hegelian you know does that mean that
he's just applying some things that
Hegel had already worked out maybe but
would Nietzsche voted for Trump
definitely not I mean it's it's funny
because you have these people like
saying yeah Trump is a Nietzschean
character he's kind of a Machiavellian
character I don't think he represents
Nietzschean ISM at all I mean he's kind
of a goof and you know it's it's clear
that he doesn't have iron self-control
because he can't help from getting in
fights with everybody on Twitter I don't
I don't think there's a great master
plan behind him
and he you know what he's been
successful in primarily is in convincing
people to give him money and second
chances and to you know let him have a
shot at trying things out no you did tap
into a lot of rage but I think a lot of
the rage that he tapped into is quite
frankly from a Nietzschean perspective
slave morality ressentiment
so III don't see him as
as a particularly Nietzschean figure I
see him as the sort of thing where
Nietzsche and would look at it and be
like see see how screwed up our culture
is not that his opponents were any
better you know whether we're talking
about the the bench of Republican
candidates or you know what what the
Democrats put forward or even what the
third parties were able to put forward I
think Nietzsche would look at most of
our political class and say these are
all people who are basically living out
one form of slave morality or another he
would not be particularly optimistic
about it anyone hate what the you know
the media on both sides have been doing
as well right Bob asks have you read
Oscar Wilde soul of man under socialism
has a very needy an edge and I have not
read it I would like to that would be
kind of interesting I've gotten you know
I like I like wild I actually just
finally read Solomon which we had laying
around here for the first time it was a
pretty cool book about not book play
right it's a short play and Wilde is an
interesting person to to check out Shaw
also was you know playing around with
Nietzsche and ideas
Chesterton writes against nature there's
kind of a great you know sort of back
and forth happening in in British
literature with Nietzsche in the later
part of the 19th century and into the
early part of the 20th century I would
say so yeah going back to neo played you
Andrews on Sam on slave morality
reactive applies to Hillary Rodham
Clinton more I wouldn't I wouldn't say
more I would say you know once you've
crossed a certain threshold of it
there's probably enough of it that
doesn't matter it's it's all reactive
stuff in one way or
there this is kind of an interesting
topic you know people like I remember
you know reading Nietzsche as a late
adolescence you know in my teens and
trying to live out this this sort of
stuff and realize you know looking back
and I realizing I totally misunderstood
what it would mean to be to be
Nietzschean you know according to
nature's own own ideas about it but I
guess that's kind of par for the course
that you could say the same thing about
so many other philosophies all right
Heraclitus writes I think the main
problem with stoicism is that they
underestimate anger which is part of our
nature I think if the anger is channeled
correctly it can be a force against
fascism yeah I mean I I'm an agreement
with parts of that I don't think that
fighting fascism is part is the most
important thing to do with properly
channeled anger I would you know I don't
have a sort of that sort of mono centric
view on it I think it's enough to stand
up to bullies perhaps who probably
aren't fascists or to do you know many
other things with it and and I would say
that you know what you're saying there
fits in with what Aristotle and the
playtest tradition say and this is where
they differ from the Stoics I you know I
mean if you think that the main problem
with the Stoics is that they
underestimate anger I would say read
some more and you'll probably find other
things where you disagree with them
because that strikes me as you know a
very very specific criticism to make and
I think there's lots of other points
where people might criticize the Stoics
you know lack of a faculty psychology
for example which is what the you know
not understanding how anger could be
useful I think fits in with its a
broader topic you know the play tennis
and Aristotelian recognize different
parts of the soul one of which is the
part where you get angry with Stoics
don't let me say you know look it's all
either the ruling faculty or the other
stuff but it's all the same
mind but you know to say that here's
another interesting thing though - yes
getting angry the capacity for that is
part of our nature that said plate inist
s' aristotelian x' even you know
somebody arguing it from a Nietzschean
perspective would say the anger that
most people feel is off-base and
misguided and leads them astray and
becomes vicious and and isn't life
affirming even if it does serve useful
purposes some of the time we can easily
go really off-the-wall with it and we
generate habits and and we often become
prisoners of these habits and not just
habits but also narratives and so you
might say relationship dynamics and this
is where something like Nietzsche and
rose anthem up can can come in and I
think need to one of the great
contributions I think nature really does
make and that's not happening by the way
the birth of tragedy it's happening
later on is his analysis of reason
talent and how it arises how it
manifests itself I think he's dead on
with that I also would recommend mock
sailors work on it where he takes
Nietzsche's idea and expands it a bit
Bob asks what do I think of Dziedzic
well that's a hard question to answer
because I'll tell you this I don't read
most of what Jesus writes because they
don't have the time
sometimes gee Jack says stuff and I and
I read it and I'm like yeah I think
that's pretty dead-on including a lot of
the stuff that he writes you know sort
of on the fly in the contemporary
political realm sometimes I read the
stuff when I'm like man this guy is just
playing around with ideas and you know
sort of like throwing stuff in the wall
and seeing what might stick and there's
a lot of people who can hero worship him
and and are willing to grant him all
sorts of stuff or they just like him
around because he's very you know
strange guy and it seems to be quite
entertaining and you could definitely
count on him to say something crazy
every every so often so for me I can't
arrange is over the gamut I don't think
that a hundred years from now we're
gonna look back and say that he's an
important person to read in order to
understand you know what was happening
in terms of great philosophy in the 21st
century but he's interesting I don't
think that he's he's not worth reading I
just don't have the time to actually
spend much time on that there's so many
other people out there to look at but I
know he's you know you can certainly
fill a room right so there that that's
kind of cool that there's a philosopher
who people want to bring in that sign
belém is that the same as a resentful
can you expand so so Nietzsche diagnoses
what he calls resentiment and you know
that's a French term that you can
translate as its cognate resentment
BOCES there is a dynamic in which the
human being normally wants to retaliate
against you know injury insult
disrespect and is unable to do so and
that effect of you know wanting to
retaliate doesn't go away it gets sort
of repressed it gets pushed down
I mean Freud is talking about something
similar to right and it's going to come
out in in other ways and eventually if
this happens enough it becomes part of
the personality something that infects
an entire culture or a range of culture
so a lot of what we call passive
aggressiveness Nietzsche would diagnose
as result among
how do people become passive-aggressive
you know
Nietzsche thinks that it also has to do
with a tendency to try to lower things
trying to tear everything down this this
desire to like you know bring everything
down not just not to raise everybody to
the same level right but to bring
everybody down in the same level so
Nietzsche himself thinks that
contemporary you know attempts to you
know socialize things or democratize
things or to make things equal really
represent resultant and he might be
wrong about that
you know they don't represent a sort of
noble nature so the noble person can
either retaliate because they they have
the guts to do so or they're really able
to let things go the the lower nature
kind of keeps holds on to all the stuff
and become sick in the process and you
know with time this can become part of
an entire culture and that's what nature
thinks has been happening in in the West
for a long time
artistic Canute's
right so it would have been interesting
for Nietzsche to talk about mirrors and
it's contemporary extension cameras as a
development of the self and the collapse
of virtues yeah you know if Nietzsche
had been healthier and it lived longer
who knows what kind of stuff we would
have got out of him but you know
unfortunately he he really wasn't that
healthy and he went insane and that
really curtailed his his career cuz he
was really an interesting uh you know
observer of culture and and he he had a
lot of depth to what he was sort of
thinking out here quite as a fetus
rights what do I think of Albert Camus I
like him quite a bit
one of the things I really like about
[ __ ] was you know he was somewhat
who really tried to think out the the
modern situation
and I mean you see this great transition
from the early stuff like you know the
stranger and you know the mythos if Isis
to the more mature work like you know
the plague and the fall and his is you
know response to the mythos if assist
the rebel Camus doesn't have easy
solutions for us but he does put his
finger on a lot of important pulses you
might say you know the he sort of like
thinks oh well what would it be to live
in an absurd universe and how can we
manage it and I you know people often
said like you know Camus was the better
novelist and Sartre was the better
philosopher I don't really agree with
that I think I actually really enjoy
cow Moos philosophical works I enjoy
Sartre as well and I actually think this
is pretty good novelists do you know but
yes come who is somebody who you know
you might say it's kind of like a fellow
traveler somebody who you could you
could imagine having a great
conversation with and not necessarily
finding yourself in agreement with which
is which is important in in philosophy
all right we're getting close to the end
of the hour why don't we take any final
questions or comments and then we will
call it a day in the meantime I'll say
some some really excellent questions and
comments giving me some some good things
to think about myself I enjoy you know
spending time on Nietzsche oh okay Bob
reminded me I missed one of his where do
I think Hegel would lie in our weird
complex political spectrum
egle like most other philosophers that
we study would find himself disgusted by
and unable to find himself a home in our
current political spectrum here in the
United States our spectrum is basically
two to coalition's
both of which are largely deluding
themselves about what good they're doing
and are mostly concerned about taking or
keeping power then that's the Democrats
and the Republicans I think Hagel would
not in good conscience be able to to
align himself with either of those I
mean you want somebody who's kind of
similar to Hagel in that respect look at
Alistair McIntyre and you know see where
he fits in the political spectrum Bob
rates I don't I don't just mean an
American liberal politics but the wider
radical political spectrum I don't know
I don't even know what that means
the wider radical political spectrum I
mean you just talk you just talking
about people on the Left who sometimes
they're aligned with the party or not
most of them are totally ineffective and
disorganized and I mean what Hagel have
come in and been like oh great potential
here for me to to do something with I
don't know
all right so Bob clarifies by saying
like socialist communist fascist
traditionalist anarchists the crazy
should as well yeah I mean these are
terms that that mean a million different
things but you know I don't see when it
comes to actual political organization
and getting things done not many of them
in the liberal democracies are doing
much of anything you know so I don't
think Hagel would would be jumping into
some you know some fascist salary
you know lining himself up with the if
you understood the traditionalist I mean
the dark Enlightenment or something like
that
I don't think he'd be doing that at all
he might be the sort of sitting back at
a distance and you know looking at them
with kind of a cold eye and and trying
to chronicle it but but they're they're
pretty ineffective except in you know a
few places as far as I can tell on both
the far right and the far left where
we're kind of stuck in a really crappy
situation and here in America we're
stuck in the worst in a certain respect
in that it's very difficult to change
because what it would require to change
the current party system would require
the parties to actually want to change
it and that's not going to happen
there's too much money and power and
tradition involved to do that there's
better prospects in the you might say in
the younger democracies than there are
in this one well that would be that
would be an interesting thing to think
about
from Hegel's perspective he did think in
terms of like all right where is where's
the real progress going to take place if
it does take place which which country
can it happen in I don't know I'd have
to really think about that from a
Hegelian perspective where where can we
look right now and see you know history
marching in some anything that looks
like the right direction I have a hard
time coming up with that because
everywhere I look I see some something
that's problematic you know I guess it's
just a question of which is less
problematic it's definitely not going to
be Russia or China or or at this point
in time India it's it's probably not the
EU I'm pretty sure it's not Britain
definitely not personal it's not the
United States you know and Hegel
wouldn't like picks on some little tiny
place and like say well you know the the
Finns have got things right because you
know it's got to be something that can
actually really galvanize the world
yeah that's a good question so that's
kind of a that's kind of a downer to end
on but that's what we're going to do and
so you know to swing it back to
Nietzsche the question I guess for us
would be if we get away from the Galleon
perspective you know and we think about
it more in terms of Nietzsche how do we
how do we deal with this how how do we
as individuals address the the lousy
situation that that we've inherited and
so that's that's a good that's a good
question for us all right I'm gonna wish
all of you guys a great weekend and stop
the broadcast but thank you before I do
that again for your questions and
comments